du jour on va revenir sur cette séquence
qui a fait polémique cette semaine Jean
Messia la pousse un coup de gueule
contre un étudiant étranger qui avait
appelé dans la rue euh les gens à se
mobiliser contre la réforme des
retraites une séquence qui a fait le
buzz mais qui n'a pas du tout plu à Jean
Messia qui a été voilà voilà il regarde
vous allez voir il a été il était très
énervé et chez Jean-Marc Morandini sur
ses news Jean Messi a été vénère de ouf
avant de voir ce qu'a dit Jean Messi on
va d'abord regarder le discours de ce
fameux étudiant qui s'appelle medizena
et qui fait partie du collectif
Révolution Permanente Jean Messia sera
avec nous et Karim ziabat c'est pas le
danseur
conseiller municipal divers gauche à
Cergy sera là également vous allez voir
cette histoire qui a fait énormément
parler et c'est le retour de Jean bessia
voilà avoir quelques costumes il porte
tous les étudiants à tous les étudiants
étrangers faut qu'on soit main dans la
main contre cette loi raciste
nous ce qu'on veut dire je connais pas
ici par hasard ils sont venus nous
chercher en Afrique
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas
vus ici et aujourd'hui ça fait de la
peine de voir nous avons nos
grands-parents crever au travail alors
on va voir ce que vous avez dit
Jean-Michel merci d'être là Jean-Michel
merci très beau costume en tout cas
merci à vous et on est très heureux
aussi de recevoir Karim ziabat
conseiller municipal divergo ça charge
qui va aller très loin vous allez voir
retenez-le non évidemment allez voir
vous verrez tu seras nommé ministre ou
viendrait
chez le pif j'avais dit pareil pour
Gilles Verdez j'avais dit qu'il aurait
une émission sur scène nous ce qu'elle
durait deux semaines
ou ça va durer beaucoup plus longtemps
c'est quand même vous allez voir allez
Jean Messia très très violemment réagi
au discours de ce jeune étudiant de
l'Université Paris 8 regardez
étudiant étranger qui se mettent en
colère alors que normalement écoute
écoute un peu les gens alors que
normalement comme c'est un étudiant
étranger
à parler
aujourd'hui dans un tellement pas la
ramener pour aujourd'hui
alors
Jean Messia vous étiez vous étiez vénère
je suis vénère parce que je ne supporte
pas qu'on dise du mal de la France et
surtout pas quand on est étranger
il y a une règle même quand on est
touriste et qu'on va dans un pays c'est
de respecter les us et les coutumes et
de respecter le pays dans lequel on est
là on n'est pas là-dedans on est dans le
cas d'un étudiant étranger que la France
accueille que la France finance que la
France aide à travers tout un tas de
dispositifs comme des bourses des aides
au logement la couverture sociale etc je
ne comprends pas comment un étudiant qui
est étranger qui a statut étranger à qui
la France donne toutes ses libéralités
viennent ainsi troubler l'ordre public
alors qu'il manifeste une colère contre
une loi je veux bien mais qui traite la
loi de retraite la réforme des retraites
comme une réforme raciste et qui en
profite ensuite pour déverser une sorte
de de glose haineuse à l'encontre du
pays qu'il accueille et qu'il finance
moi fondamentalement ça m'a choqué quand
il nous parle du colonialisme du fait
que ses parents ont construit la Tour
Eiffel on du métro faut juste préciser à
ce monsieur que si c'est grand-parents
avaient construit la Tour Eiffel ils
auraient 130 ans et si ou entre 130 et
150 ans ils font peut-être partie de ces
retraités qui vivent en Algérie et qui
continue à toucher les les retraites
alors qu'ils sont morts depuis belle
lurette mais
je comprends pas si vous voulez donc
dans n'importe quel pays au monde un
étranger qui trouble l'ordre public un
étranger qui trouble de l'ordre public
est immédiatement expulsé en lui
supprime son titre de séjour et on
l'expulse donc moi la question que j'ai
envie de poser c'est est-ce que c'est
étudiant étranger n'est pas allée trop
loin parce que c'est facile de me tomber
dessus dans ma réaction mais encore
faut-il interroger cette étudiant
étranger et lui demander si lui n'est
pas allé trop loin en insultant la
France de la manière dont il l'a faite
alors qu'il est accueilli par la France
et les Français j'ai fait c'est la
phrase la plus longue de l'histoire de
l'émission l'intervention la plus longue
de l'histoire de l'émission je suis là
pour la changer merci alors révolue
on va déjà écouter Révolution Permanente
ils ont réagi à vos attaques Jean-Michel
sur Twitter et en vidéo les avez vu vous
avez vu la radio
de Paris 8 qui s'est pris une offensive
réac de tous les fachos de Twitter après
qu'il est osé prendre la parole à la
marche des solidarités hier il a été
rappelé que la France est un État
colonial et raciste et pour ça il s'est
pris toutes les offensives réac et facho
de la terre entière la vérité c'est
qu'en fait ils ont la rage quand un
arabe ou un noir prend la parole et pas
de politique la vérité c'est qu'ils ont
le seum quand les merci organise pas de
politique bon en manifestation donc pour
tout ça en fait on lui envoie toute la
solidarité et on arrêtera jamais face au
facho j'ai une question à poser moi je
suis à l'arabe qui prend la parole je me
suis pas énervé vis-à-vis de moi-même
fort
c'est dire à quel point son discours est
idiot Karim conseiller municipal divers
Go ça chirurgicale qu'est-ce que vous
trouvez que c'était trop de lui dire
ferme ta gueule quand j'entends les
propos de Jean Messia au-delà de ce
qu'on a habitué à entendre de lui c'est
à dire de la malhonnêteté intellectuelle
et de la bêtise ce qui me choque moi
profondément c'est que ça me fait penser
une séquence la semaine dernière on a eu
beaucoup de gens qui ont commencé à dire
bah écoutez finalement les gens des
banlieues autrement dit pour certains
les noirs et les Arabes les étrangers on
les voit pas dans les manifestations ils
prennent pas position dans cette réforme
qui va les impacter et là aujourd'hui on
a un étudiant étranger qui a pris la
parole pour manifester son
mécontentement légitime sur la réforme
des retraites et on a Jean Messia qui
vient donner finalement le droit de
parler au pas parler alors même que un
des droits les plus fondamentaux en
France c'est comme la liberté
d'expression et ce qu'on entend
finalement de chez Jean messieurs c'est
que la liberté d'expression elle varie
si on est étranger ou pas et elle varie
aussi si on est dans la rue sur un
plateau parce que là lui il a selon lui
la légitimité de parler parce que il est
sur un plateau dans sa belle chemise
sont après ça chacun jugera la beauté
c'est un petit consultant petit alpaga
voilà c'est rien c'est 40% polyester de
20% polyamide
mais ce qu'il dérange finalement c'est
que quand la rue elle s'exprime à
travers des visages qui sont pas ceux
que lui il a envie de voir quand on a un
jeune qui s'appelle Mehdi qui prend la
parole ça le dérange et fondamentalement
il y a quelque chose qui je sais qui
vous dérange c'est que Mehdi quand il
prend la parole dans la rue il a la même
légitimité que vous vous sur un plateau
parce que vous avez pas plus de
légitimité que mes yeux et Mehdi si
s'oppose à la réforme des retraites il
est légitime il est même plus légitime
que vous mais là là
pourquoi est-ce qu'il est plus légitime
que vous parce que Mehdi il est dans la
rue il fait vivre la démocratie vous
qu'est-ce que vous faites à part passer
en fait moi j'ai une question à vous
poser vous savez à quoi en France ben je
sais à ce que vous vous ne servez pas
c'est-à-dire à réveiller les Français
contre le discours que des gens comme
vous colporte ils ont un discours
demande un étudiant étranger qui est
contre la réforme des retraites de
fermer sa gueule est-il allé trop loin
genre est-ce que vous trouvez que vous
avez été trop loin Jean non non par
contre j'ai trouvé que Mehdi a été trop
loin parce qu'en plus il falsifie
l'histoire je sais bien que le
gouvernement nous explique que nous
accueillons des historiens des artistes
des des médecins des ingénieurs il
falsifie l'histoire si effectivement
c'est parents et ses grands-parents avec
construit la Tour Eiffel le métro
pourquoi pas Notre-Dame et le
Mont-Saint-Michel tant qu'il y ait
mais à ce moment-là je trouve un truc
que je comprends pas là pourquoi c'est
parents ils ont pas construit la même
chose dans leur pays d'origine
Sylvie falsifie l'histoire vous
falsifier le présent mais je vous écoute
répondez la question
mais c'est plus intéressant je veux bien
connaître les étrangers la France
que les Français n'aient rien construit
que la France elle s'est construite
uniquement sur l'immigration que toutes
les guerres de la France
que l'immigration maghrébine ou
africaine les migration pour Monsieur
polonaise alors j'aimerais qu'on reste
aussi là tu Gilles Verdun derrière vous
bien sûr mais le discours de Jean-Michel
il est comme d'habitude tenter de
neocolonialisme de haine de l'étranger
voire de racisme là en l'occurrence Jean
et vous êtes totalement parce que
Révolution Permanente je porte plein de
contre eux pour racisme je l'annonce sur
le plateau TPMP j'ai demandé à mon
avocat conseil maître Pichon parce que
la Révolution Permanente me traite de
racisme et de nazi j'ai porté plainte
pour diffamation et pour un jour public
votre discours était tenté de je fais
attention à ce que je dis c'est mettre
le Pichon
les maltés
un pigeon maltais
pas
non mais derrière tout ça il y a votre
haine de l'étranger c'est ça qui est
insupportable vous savez que les
étudiants étrangers ils rapportent plus
d'un milliard d'euros chaque année à la
France l'État dépense 3 millions 7 pour
les accueillir et eux ils dépensent 100
milliards en France ils font vivre nos
commerces c'est faux mais
c'est les derniers chiffres vous pouvez
pas nier les chiffres vous nier l'effet
vous n'y allez pas nier les chiffres il
dépense dans le commerce comme vous
dites avec le pognon que la France leur
donne donc c'est un cercle vicieux en
fait
trois
des étudiants étrangers qui viennent du
continent africain et ça qui vous
dérange c'est bon il y a deux mensonges
que vous répétez en boucle c'est votre
fantasme c'est votre musique et vous
répétez partout le premier c'est que les
immigrés et les étrangers ne payent pas
d'impôts c'est faux ils payent des
impôts comme tout le monde ensemble si
vous l'avez dit dans votre réaction à ce
soir et deuxièmement les Zinédine paient
pas d'impôts par exemple mais bien sûr
la France je vous ai laissé faire votre
tunnel très ennuyeux maintenant
laissez-moi terminer quand quand un
étudiant arrive ici en France vous savez
qu'il doit payer des frais de scolarité
contrairement à ce que vous dites vous
avez dit un étudiant étranger ne paye
pas c'est faux vous savez combien il
doit payer ou pas il paye 3 apparemment
entre 3000 et 4000 € de l'année en
fonction en fonction du cycle exactement
par rapport à un étudiant français c'est
1170 euros pour une licence 2700
mentez donc falsifier le présent
reprenez les éléments factuels vous vous
trouvez pas
des retraites là c'est la liberté
d'expression
je lui ai reproché d'avoir insulté la
France et d'avoir vomi son fiel rageux
sur la France voilà ce que je reproche
qui qu'il parle de la réforme des
retraites qui critiquent un certain
nombre de savoir c'est sa liberté
d'expression mais je ne veux pas qu'on
insulte mon pays alors même que ce sont
les Français qui le payent c'est tout
c'est vous dites NON vous aussi parce
que j'en essaye il est dans son
personnage il est devenu influenceur en
fait il veut il veut faire le buzz et il
veut choquer donc là il a choqué une
fois de plus et je suis contre vous à
100% sur que votre je suis un peu
d'accord avec toi je dis non parce qu'il
est il va pas trop loin penser de pas
l'interroger
ou pas que pour moi il veut pas trop
parce qu'il est dans son personnage ça
fait des années qu'il a le même discours
elle-même il parle toujours pareil des
ça arrive effectivement de l'étranger et
effectivement il est pas étroit pour lui
et Delphine
en même temps j'en mets ça fait ce que
tous les politiques font c'est-à-dire
faire des bras d'honneur peut-être mal
parler peut-être voilà emmerder les
Français fermer sa gueule voilà on est
sur un registre comme ça où les gens
alors on peut on peut comprendre ou pas
mais bon en ce moment le la forme de de
des politiques c'est un peu compliqué
quoi quand il s'exprime alors moi je
valide pas la forme je déteste les
insultes je les dis et je le redis en
revanche j'ai été choqué
j'ai été choquée par le discours
insultant de ce de ce jeune homme qui
critique la réforme des retraites je la
critique aussi donc voilà on a tous
notre liberté d'expression maintenant
qui traite la France de pays racistes et
toutes les autres insultes qu'il a donné
je m'étonne de voir qu'il ait envie même
de vivre ici alors que vraiment ils
pensent ça de notre pays alors pourquoi
il a envie d'être ici ils disent à
Béatrice sauf que c'est pas la question
qu'on nous pose la question dont nous
qu'on nous pose est-ce que tu trouves
que Jean Messia est allé est allé trop
loin dans la forme justement et donc moi
dans la forme je trouve qu'il est allé
et dans le fond et moi je pense que le
garçon en question dise que la France
est raciste moi je pense qu'il a
totalement tort donc voilà mais il y
avait tellement d'autres façons de dire
je et sur le fond que il a tort et
expliquer pour quelle raison plutôt que
de lui dire tu es discrédité parce que
tu n'as pas le droit de parler parce que
tu es un étranger ben là en l'occurrence
c'est pas possible en disant ferme ta
gueule et fermer le banc circuler il y a
rien à voir je suis pas d'accord là
c'est là où je trouve que j'en mets ça
fait une erreur avec toi sur la forme
mais je voudrais juste dire quelque
chose rajouter quelque chose c'est à
l'heure actuelle on ne peut plus avoir
parler d'un seul sujet sans que tombe ou
le le racisme l'antisémitisme le
complotisme enfin toutes ces étiquettes
qui tuent les débats absolument alors
que à la base on parle d'une réforme des
retraites pourquoi on finit toujours sur
du racisme l'antisémitisme
ça suffit
sur une simple réforme des retraites qui
a vraiment rien à voir avec la
choucroute il y a un type qui la ramène
avec du racisme de l'esclavagisme du
colonialisme etc
on est pression d'accueillir la braderie
donc je voudrais je voudrais Karim et
après j'en terminera
que les propos d'après peut-être déraper
ça c'est un débat mais sur le fond la
réforme en elle-même elle est
discriminante sur plein de sujets sur
les étrangers parce que c'est souvent
eux qui ont les métiers les plus
pénibles donc c'est des gens qui vont
avoir des carrières beaucoup de
pénibilité les premiers cordés les
premières lignes elle est aussi quelque
part c'est parce que c'est souvent les
femmes qui ont des carrières hachées qui
ont des métiers aussi les plus pénibles
que quand on parle des caissières des
infirmières c'est souvent des femmes des
métiers qui sont difficiles je suis
d'accord ils vont devoir travailler
encore plus jusqu'à 64 ans donc la
réforme elle est à la fois discriminante
sur les femmes à la fois sur les
étrangers et sur tout un tas d'autres
sujets maintenant vous votre fond de
commerce c'est le racisme qu'est-ce que
c'est vous qui raciste en l'occurrence
tout le monde pourquoi la rationaliser
je la race
français qui font des métiers
positifs qui vous intéresse c'est
l'erreur qui sont qui sont dans le BTP
qui sont égoutiers pourquoi racialiser
la réforme la réforme elle est un jour
mais ça je suis d'accord
et pourquoi la réalité vous vous êtes
canules de la République comme vous
canellules de la République
ose soutenir un langage anti-uns le
soutenir
encore deux mois vous êtes là vous êtes
là pour le Défi
moi je me suis grave calmé
je trouve ça très grave que des élus de
la République et ça prouve à quel point
la haine de la France est portée à très
haut niveau que des élus de la
République que des médias puissent
soutenir ce discours anti-français
anti-national porté qui plus est par un
étranger c'est très inquiétant une une
confluence des luttes pas celle que vous
pensez une confluence des luttes contre
la France
de plateau en plateau qui n'est rien
dans la société qui n'apporte rien à la
France
je rencontre et qui vivent des
difficultés qu'est-ce qui vivent la
réforme
dans un conseil municipal que personne
ne connaît d'abord j'étais hier soir en
conseil municipal à Cergy et salut les
collègues et en plus de ça mon travail
c'est tous les jours sur le terrain de
9h à 20h vous avez vous êtes insolent et
arrogant voilà ce que voilà ce que vous
dites mais je vous l'ai déjà dit j'en
mets juste un guignol qui passe
vous n'êtes pas responsable politique
parce qu'en responsable politique c'est
quelqu'un de responsable politique vous
n'avez rien de responsable vous êtes
juste
blabla ah les amis
il insulte
pas parce que toi avec ton institut
Apollon que tu dirais
pas de ça ouais
vous êtes un journaliste des froquets
alors arrêtez pourquoi on peut continuer
comme ça longtemps hein
il sera lui il a suffisamment le niveau
bon allez Géraldine s'il te plaît non
mais moi j'ai pas relevé niveau
forcément mais déjà non mais j'ai pas
dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
éventuellement de loubayeur moi je pense
que loubayeur aurait été à côté cette
étudiant étranger et aurait dit
exactement la même chose que lui parce
qu'il a les amis les amis de Gilles
absolument
après monsieur Messia
arrêtez avec vos amalgames en faites le
problème c'est que vous pouvez
éventuellement valoriser la France en
disant moi j'aime qu'on aime mon pays je
veux pas qu'on critique ça et après vous
allez tout de suite beaucoup trop loin
quand vous dites par exemple oui voilà
il a son grand-père qui doit être mort
parce qu'il est aussi lavé construit la
Tour Eiffel il aurait 150 ans il doit
être en Algérie en fait voilà avec des
arnaques et tout mais vous avez des
chiffres vous avez des données mais non
mais attendez c'est comme ça
la seule partie de la culture générale
de la soirée
c'est l'Afghanistan c'est comme Bardella
qui dit que trap c'est une république
islamiste c'est-à-dire que le problème
c'est que mais non
j'ai juste dit
en fait on est prêt on est tous entre
deux extraits
merci merci et calmos Ramos merci
d'avoir été là merci jean-baptia d'avoir
été là merci merci Karim ziabat d'avoir
été là c'est toujours animé voilà c'est